today i would like to talk about a
package that i've been working on for
quite a while now
and
which i
and of which i decided to to publish it
and this package is called uh deep
docked action and as a subtitle already
says
it is an open source open source package
for document intelligence
or a different subtitle might be a
toolbox for getting text
out of complex structured documents
and before we get started let me
introduce myself a little bit
further so my name is janis i've got a
background in mathematics
and i've been consulting for financial
services for more than 13 years now
and
during my consultant work
i'm more involved in the business area
of in the business units of controlling
accounting
risk repo risk control
but also regulatory reporting so these
are all business units where you don't
really expect a lot of machine learning
and of deep learning as well
however
you will encounter a lot
of use cases
where you might think of
how you can apply these kind of new
techniques in order to simplify
or to optimize work
and this was actually the trigger
why i started working on this package
because during a project a couple of
years ago in a bank
i
find out that
a lot of people were involved in
extracting key figures out of financial
reports
to be a little bit more concrete the
business case was
that for regulatory reporting banks need
to report
their investments in mutual funds
for the central bank not on a
front level but on the underlying asset
level
and this requires a lot of work
in order to gather all these different
information sometimes the banks need to
collect they need to ask the fund
manager themselves
in some other cases the only way to get
these informations
will
require
going through semi-annual or annual
reports of these documents
and extract
so that means copy paste these
informations of these documents out of
these documents
to
normalize these data
and finally
to get it ready in order to load it to a
database
so
quite a tedious work
and um
i was thinking uh
about the problem
how can you automate this how can you
automate this thing
and
the actual
step was at the first
the first native approach quite
straightforward the first thing is that
you somehow need to parse the document
and on the second thing you need to do
something with nlp whatsoever
and
when i try to work on this problem i got
already stuck at the very first place
namely
i had the problem how do i get all these
informations which are often
trapped in pdf documents or maybe even
scanned documents how can you get this
information out of these documents in
order to process them even further
and if you think about
about what do you have to do when having
this complex structure document
there are several things you need to
take care of
so the first one is
maybe discovering the rough layout
structure which in also includes
detecting the table structure
but you also need to get the text out in
a way
that it actually makes sense so if
you've got a complex structured document
with several columns it is not trivial
to get these documents to get
the reading order of the text out
in a sensible way
and in some other cases you have to link
some types of tables with the
surrounding text
in order to identify the content of the
table correctly
so these were the actual the
the problem i faced
and
nevertheless i started working and
exploring some tools
i started working with
just
open source
pdf pathing documents they try to
reconstruct the layout structure based
on the text they find
however if you want to
process them further
these results were
quite mediocre and certainly not enough
in order to get
your work done
so
the next thing
the next step was to to go much deeper
into the subject and try
to find out what's going on on the reach
research site site
and
when i started it was around
2019 there were actually quite a few
papers out there who
suggested to use deep learning so for
example it was already common case that
object detectors work quite well with
detecting layout structures
however there was another problem
it was really difficult to get annotated
data
and
the other
thing the other problem was simply that
you had to
implement a lot
by yourself
there were some repos with some open
research code out there but if you try
to
use some research code in order to
get to try something out you will
end up
with a lot of frustration
because research code is not really
useful
for applying it to some real world
problems
so
this is why i started
developing this package
deep
and
yes
so let me just say
[Music]
some words about the main about basic
features
so
when you want to tackle this type of
problems of decomposing this document
into a
structure that you can process further
so you want somehow to parse this
document
and
the easiest way to do this is by
decomposing the problem into several
small pieces
and
this ends up by setting up a pipeline
so one of the main features of this
package is
the fact or is the idea
to
build pipelines depending on your
personal needs in order to decompose
this
document
so let's start with one example i think
that's the easiest way to understand
what you need to do
suppose you have this type of
document which has
ordinary document structure with headers
with titles text and so forth
the very first thing that you need to do
in case you have an image in case you
have a pdf you need to load it
and you need to convert it into a tensor
and
at the very first thing you try to
recover the
document structure the rough document
structure by identifying the course
layout structure namely title text
blocks and tables
and
you can do this by
applying
a deep learning model a detection model
which works quite well
provided that it is it has been properly
trained
and
you get all these results back the
bounding boxes back
and
on the next thing
you
maybe want to investigate further on the
table structure so you crop you need you
need to crop the table out of the
document
and apply maybe
a
second
model
which is
an expert model for determining the
table structure namely determining
the cell structure of the table
the rows
as well as the columns
and
these results which are calculated
based on the relative coordinates of the
crop document of the crop page
needs to be reconverted
in terms of absolute coordinates of the
document
and after that you need to infer
the
row the row number to each cell the
column number to each cell the row span
the column span and you can do this for
example by looking at how much does the
cell intersect with the detected row and
the detected column in order to get a
segmentation of the table
so what's next the next step is actually
something which
involves extracting text so this can be
an ordinary
ocr approach
or
in case of pdf documents you don't
really need ocr
in many times
very often so you can just
rely
on some pdf miners for excel for example
so
the next step requires extracting the
text
and once you've got all these
informations together you need somehow
to create
some sensible structure out of it you
remember at the end you need to get some
proper floating text out of it
and right at this point you only have
some text bounding boxes
so
next step you need to perform some some
matching in order to match the
text bounding boxes with the underlying
table with the underlying layout
structure that you
recovered earlier
and after that you need to group these
text information see word informations
you need to order them in order to get
some proper text out of this
and at the final step you need to create
an output structure
which you can load maybe in your
favorite nlp library
so this is one of the main features that
you can
actually combine different steps of
different parsing steps
according to your needs according to
your document you want to
you you want to recover
and at the next
step
which is the second feature is
how do we get
all these models which are on the right
side
which
are part of the
pipeline as well
and this is the second feature actually
that
this package comes equipped
with
some um
some external packages which you can
load according to your needs
and
that
and that contains some models uh
like pre-trained models on some specific
tasks like like
layout detection
or table segmentation
there are also some light wrappers for
very popular ocr libraries like
tessa act
i've also discovered a less known
ocr library
which gives actually some very decent
results
or you can also use instead of an ocr
library if you have some native pdf
documents
pdf plumber for example which is also
contained as a library wrapper and
you can load
these
external packages
by yourself
and just use them
straight away
and
the idea is that you pick one model
for a specific task you plug it into the
backbone of a pipeline
and the backbone of the pipeline is just
there
for
the orchestration for gathering all
these informations recalculating
the necessary values
and grouping
the results
so
when i started
[Music]
i
said that collecting data is actually
very difficult
and
i already said that i have
prepared some pre-trained model which
are based
which are there for
retrieving the layout as well as
for
retrieving the dock the table structure
of a document
and
fortunately
there were two data sets available
a couple of years ago which are quite
large
and
which
give a good
baseline for
actually
detecting
these document structures
so
regarding this
regarding these two data sets they are
coming from the same source
which is uh the um
pmc which is
public medical center open access subset
and the
the type of documents they contain are
only research articles from medical
documents from medical
reports so
if you want to apply this to your
specific use case so
say for
evaluating the layout of business
reports
you cannot expect
that these pre-trained models will work
well
on
your
specific on your custom data set
so
this is the next feature
that you somehow need to fine-tune
these pre-trained models
um according to you need
and for that i have also provided some
training script that allows you to
provided you have a data set at hand
to fine-tune
these
pre-trained models on your specific use
case
and to give you a number
of um how well do these models perform
um
when you start evaluating these
detection models on the layout detection
task
and
you will get on the public net data set
so provided you
do the test evaluation
of the layout detection on the public
net
test set
a quite good
result so it is around
0.9
mean average precision which is quite
high in which it's already enough in
order to get some results
uh
correctly processed
however if you apply it to
a
specific business use case
as i applied to namely to my business
reports
you get a significant drop of the layout
detection so
when i set up a test data set
composed of
about 500 manually hand labeled
documents from
um
from from business report
the original performance dropped from
0.9 to 0.5
on the other hand
you have some techniques
on which you might
again increase the performance just by
putting a bias
on the model that is
you can just fine-tune the model on a
training set of business documents
and
if you do this
in a
somehow a clever way that is that you
select
a wide range of
business documents and you don't only
choose one specific corporate layout
documents but actually select from a
wide range
and
you
even improve this by setting up an
active learning strategy you can
actually
leverage the performance and
again to give you a number after 600
pages i got an average precision of
0.85
again just by manually labeling
with an active label strategy of 600
pages
so
another use case you can use you you can
think of
the first one included as a whole
business process
parsing the whole document
would be to filter out some specific
parts of a business document and in
order to show you at least
a few lines of python code
let me just show you how to compose
a business a pipeline with this
framework
so
at the very beginning you need to set up
a
config and some model parts some some
weights
which you can download
for example the pre-trained models are
available on hugging face
and on the second step
you need to set up your specific layout
detection model
and you plug this into the backbone of a
pipeline
at the second step
if you work on pdf documents you use
just a pdf plumber and a text extraction
tool which gives you
the text
based on words and bounding boxes
and
as already said in the first
by showing you the first pipeline you
need to set up a matching service which
tries to combine
the word structures
with the
detected layout structure from the very
beginning
and at the last step you need to
determine the reading order and for that
there is a special
pipeline backbone pipeline available as
well
and after that you just
plug them all these backbones into
a pipeline
and
if you want to run
this pipeline
so you just need to
set a path to your document and this can
be a document
containing several pages
and
you just need to call the analyze method
and this returns
and
generator
from which you can iterate
and
for convenience there is also an output
parsix structure available which gives
you some
handy features like getting
some text based on some filter condition
so in this particular use case you can
see on the right hand side that it
contains actually only the text without
the table structure and this was
intended from the beginning that i
wanted to exclude the table structure
so
this is just an overview of the
architecture of the package i don't want
to go into the details just want to let
you know if you're interested in using
it
i try to
add as much help as possible
so there are a few jupiter notebooks as
tutorials available
and
also
reads the docs has been set up
so finally
some ideas
because this is an open source project
and
there are definitely a lot of
features you can think of
for example
you can work on training a table
detector only model because the ordinary
the
currently available
layout framework detects
other features which are only involved
in
documents and
which contain several pages so if you
have
text and titles in there
this might be something that you are not
not really looking for because tables
can be contained also in invoice for
example
another thing that i would like to add
because this would fit quite well in
this framework is adding these layout
models
which you might have heard of
that also
that are a combination of visual models
and nlp models and
that
leverage
the visual structure in order to
determine
classification of documents
or even classification of tokens
so for these there are some pre-trained
models available
and it would be quite nice to add them
into this framework
yeah so
ideas and pull requests are welcome of
course
and
yeah i
hope you enjoyed the talk and thank you
very much
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so i have a couple of questions here so
i have more than
what we'll have time so for the people
that we did answer you can go and see
janice in the breaks and then ask
yourself the questions
so in the one that i have here so the
first one is quite interesting so what
is the main motivations i probably
already mentioned at the beginning but
just to recall what is the main
motivation of open sourcing basically
the
package well the main motivation is that
well it's quite it's quite difficult um
i started this project when i was
working on a very particular problem and
namely this business reports and when i
started working on that i also um
meet the some potential customers and
ask if they would be especially the bank
where i was
looking where i
detected this this frame as this problem
this is this use case
and
they came back to me and said oh yes
this problem is quite interesting but
why wouldn't you
do this kind of document extraction task
this
is actually a problem with hurts a lot
more
and that made me think that
it would be much better to generate a
general framework that
several people could use because
there are just so many use cases out
there
which require retrieving uh extra
information from from structure and so
maybe people might profit it and because
this area is so huge
uh
it wouldn't be able for just a few
people to
create a framework which works actually
quite well to solve business problems
yeah thanks
so
second one
um
what's the difference between for
instance this package and something that
i have no idea what it is but maybe you
know apache tikka
did you come over oh i
don't know anything about apache tickers
okay so
can i have further discussion there yes
so let me see
so yeah you spoke about active learning
and someone is asking like which tool do
you involve in that actions i mean in in
that process uh basically what tools
yeah this this requires not only the the
active learning but also the the
labeling tool which is because these
features are quite integrated heavily so
regarding
a tool i haven't found
unfortunately a proper open source tool
which i found very useful for for
so i use a proprietary tool
for which i also developed
some some active learning strategy based
on some reaches research paper which is
available
which is so-called ulala paper
based on that one
but
yes regarding labeling i use a
proprietary tool
i don't want to make any adwords for
that now okay
and last questions so
you mentioned that you were usually like
so you test the library on on
on pdf is there a way that you can for
instance have different input like
powerpoints pdf
images that all come together and like
other single things for everything or
well as long as you can convert uh
your original structure into an image
that means as long as you can convert it
into a
a numpy array
numpy array everything is possible
okay
so thanks again so for all the questions
that i couldn't ask feel free to to
contact yanis in the conference
thank you